はぁっ
買っちゃっぷこんにちははじめ車窓です今日はに tv について話そうと思います僕
は中学校の時3年間全部
ニキビに悩んでデータと言っても過言ではありませんまあそれくらい中学の時はニキビ
がひどかったんですけれども
高校に上がったらもうちょいなくなってってあまーいマット保護
[音楽]
ちょっと端がポロボスくらいもうで分袖だったらね今あそういうできびてぃで離れです
ねで不足によるちょっと離れが悪くない見てるじゃないんですけどもあまりできるん
ですけどもやっぱり中学校高校とかになると家になる人が多いと思うんですが僕はその
代表例
今だともわかんないんですけど本当にせる指導してきて花火はなんて管理日々が
どんどん出てきてこめかみにも
すごい対応できるのトップンってできてコバもねどちらて別々でなく本文
日影さんじゃないぞ何コンビニおでこにきびいただければ至る所にニキビが出来て市場
に悩んでました女の子にもてるもてない以前に自分にも自信がなくて羽成がやってます
神きびの薬塗っても naon ないし以下をたくさんあっても naon ないし
いろいろ高知港サッコしたんです
けど十分な音なかったです鉄拳カート中学校卒業者の自然に治ったんで真ってば治った
んですけどもなんかねお肌がブツブツだとそれ自身もてません読み切りがなぜできるか
そしてどうやって直すかって言う簡単に調べてみたら皆さんに紹介してあげましょう
ニキビもいろんな種類があるんで一概には言えないんですけども基本的なことを
しっかり理論立てて説明
するってこれをやって行けば正尚話になれば思います
4つほどねちょっと重要なテーマを絞ってきお話していこうと思いますでは行き
ましょう
握りは基本的にないんですけどもやっぱり汗かきやすいから7鼻がテカっていつもし
たらさせがベロでも仕方ないよ
人間だもその1ツインガーディきびを治すための基本になるんでしっかりスティンガー
はやってみたほうがいいでしょう線が1日1回がベストです団塊もしすると逆に肌が
乾燥し
で搬送すると多さだがやはり乾燥する本の油出さなきゃ月感想グループ逆に皮脂が発生
してまっすぐナース手のレーサーに入ります
[音楽]
ガー
洗顔料を使って随時てちゃんとあることによってニキビが良くなるかもしれません
そのについみんです
俺が言っても説得力ないなそれはね僕はもう完全に睡眠不足の人間なんてそれが食べ
終えらの本テカテカ肌の原因かもしれんですね政閔時間をしっかりとることでも肌が
再生します睡眠時間が不足すると自律神経がおかしくなってお肌の脂皮脂の分泌量が
多くなって肌がテカテカになって結果的にニキビができることにつながってしまいます
お肌
浅井停車せず日は午後の10時から午前の24時間が夫を妻で射精時間と言われており
ます
5回つの公然のよし5時6時7時発19時ぐらいに寝ますお肌をきれいにと打ちたい人
はまあ10時ごろには寝ましょうという感じですねそういう子貸切取ることはとても
大事ですちょっとねーよねそんな3 a ようです野菜とか果物まあいろんな食べ物魚
とかもあるんです
もうお肌を再生成ために必要なビタミンとが栄養がされております水のを取ることが
大事なんですけど僕みたいな野菜が嫌いだとかそもそも野菜と果物を食べるのが苦手
って人もいるかも知れませんそういう人にオススメなのがサプリメントとか溶剤とか
ですね僕たちはこれをたまに使っていますチョコラ bb
俺はねすごいそ肌荒れニキビ道府炎かぶれただれ口内炎とかと言う
グっぽいんですけども効いてるかどうかよくわかんないんですけどまぁ気持ち的な問題
ですね風面ともねそういう日度
ok 特にはとても使いやすいんですけどもやはりサプリと卵の対応拙者と呪文次元
ならで皆さんにやめましょう命の危険に及ぶことがあるかも知れませんそのようつ
トレス思春期の頃はこれが1
2番手がいいんじゃないかなと僕は思っているわけなんですよストレスが溜まることに
よく男性ホルモンが二
食べるらしい book つが実深されると働くと油っぽくなっちゃう走って脂っぽい
畑
それで原因で三木日になってしまうということがよくあるらしいです
反抗期とかね買うわけわかんないことにイラついたりするんですけれども皆
解けの心を持ちたまえよだから悪いことばかりではない嫌なこともあるし
わけわからないこともある系のそういうことにイライラしずね常にヘア
してゲットしてあんまり物事を深く考えず駅頭に過ごせばストレースなんでかかれませ
んよ
[音楽]
てわけにもいかないんですよねいろいろね悩むこともあると思うんですけども適度に
ストレスを発散することによってねなんとかなと思いますよ敵とぐらいが一番いいです
ため中学校3年間で君の戦でまぁ無駄にしたって言っても過言じゃないぐらい気にして
たんだよなんじゃないかね苦労すると思うんですけどもまたれ
うっっ
まぁ僕も本当に悩んだ人ですとてつもなくなりました
ストレスにならないようなあんまり深く考えずに年適当にケアしててもらえればいいな
と思っております接客最終的にはなんか自然と治るんでまぁなんとかなると思います
それが皆さんよかったら試してみてください
じゃあ
[音楽]
[拍手]